[music playing]
NARRATOR: At the Hawk homestead
in the remote Ozark Mountains,
tradition runs deep.
OK, what do you think?
NARRATOR: And with
every new generation
comes a new responsibility to
carry on a sacred way of life.
Having a new little
one in the family,
it's an incredible thing.
But it's a lot of
different pressure.
My primary work partner, she's
got a full time job right now.
Now that mom is taking
care of the baby,
River's been searching
to see that she's
still accepted, wanted, needed.
All right, River, you go
hurry up and finish up.
We've got to get going.
So I'm taking River out to
start showing her and teaching
her my knowledge
of the land here,
which is really neat, because
it's an opportunity for us
to start really building
our relationship even more
just as a father and daughter.
OK.
NARRATOR: Today,
nine-year-old River embarks
on a mountain rite of passage.
JASON: I'm taking her out with
me for her first hunting trip
so she understands the basic of
butchering, of how to clothe,
feed, shelter herself.
These are basic needs of human
beings living on this planet
that 90% of the people
out there don't even know.
Love you.
- Let me kiss the little rabbit.
Be good, Maddie.
RIVER: Can I kiss
the little rabbit?
NARRATOR: training begins
with the basic tools.
JASON: Set everything
down for a minute.
OK.
Well, when you start hunting,
usually your hunting gear
is given to you.
And in our family, a lot
of it's made for you.
So I made you a
little hunting hood.
Wow, dad, that's so cool.
You'll be
camouflaged, invisible.
OK, and there's one more thing.
Every hunter needs
their own tools.
NARRATOR: River's never
operated a crossbow before.
But Jason chose it
for her because it's
easier to use than
a traditional bow
and doesn't kick like a rifle.
JASON: Gently.
Get that finger
up on the trigger.
You can set up a kid and
up their chances of success
with a crossbow.
So I think it's a great
tool to get kids celebrating
and getting them excited.
Are you ready?
RIVER: Uh-huh.
JASON: You got it?
RIVER: Got it.
Squeeze the trigger.
Pretty good.
JASON: Her first
shot off the bat,
she's pretty far
from the target.
She's got some work to do.
But it's a good start.
You're in line with that target.
But you're really
shot it a lot high.
The reason we want
to be a good shot,
we do not want to
make the deer suffer.
If you hit the
deer in the heart,
the deer dies really quick.
So it's our
responsibility to make
sure that we're good shots.
You want to take another shot?
Sure.
All right, you want
to take a deep breath,
breathe, and halfway
through your breath,
squeeze the trigger.
RIVER: I have it
right on the bullseye.
Nice.
Super close.
All right, look at that.
That was a good shot.
RIVER: Yeah.
I was two fingers and a
pinky away from the bullseye.
Good deal, huh.
I'll tell you what,
I think that's close
enough that you
have earned being
able to go out hunting with me.
Let's gather up our things.
You look like you're ready.